hello vaccinated and unvaccinated alike
i don't care what you've injected
yourself when with as long as you're
watching i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it's
december 7th
2021 i believe that you can make medical
decisions for yourself that's what i
believe around here we are live
streaming of course on rumble on youtube
and on blaze tv a lot to get to today
we're mixing up the stories it's going
to be a little bit of more a little bit
more of like a hodgepodge of stories
today i didn't want to do all the covid
stuff and there's some good signs
happening something just happened about
10 minutes ago that's really great that
we'll kick off with in just a moment but
before anything else you know yesterday
we were talking about this kamala harris
woman she's the the person pretending
that she's vice president nobody really
likes her you know polling at zero in
her own party when they decided she
would be vice president because they
would just smuggle her in once joe has
to retire it doesn't seem like it's
going well either they can't control her
now there's all these stories leaking
out that people don't like her you know
this cackle and i played the video that
compilation video of the cackle
yesterday i played it i think three
times on the show and we looked in the
comment section and people were saying
dave how could you do that to us this
woman's psychotic she sounds crazy you
can't keep playing this cackle over and
over i'm nauseous i'm vomiting i i need
help it's disgusting
so we thought we have one other video
that we wanted to show
you my pretty and your little dog too
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean that's some fine work we're doing
over here you know what i mean
connor that's all connor right there
okay he wakes up he says what can i do
how can i put a little more goodness
into the world there's a little uh
kamala for you on the good news front
though seriously like now no joking
aside some great news just broke
literally within the last ten minutes or
so uh that this is a quote from the
disclose tv twitter feed a u.s federal
judge sides with attorney general wilson
and blocks biden's vaccine requirement
for federal contractors this is
absolutely fantastic before i get to a
little bit more on that real quick
as you know
another judge had blocked the private
company there was this issue around
private companies with over a hundred
employees another federal judge blocked
that it's sort of in the courts right
now or not sort of it's in the courts
right now the daily wire is the lead
uh defendant in that uh harmeet dylan is
the is the lawyer on that so that one
got hung up on the private side private
company side but now
a federal court is stepping in and
saying that the federal contractor thing
is even hung up this is this is a great
great moment we've got a little bit more
from becker news the judge granted a
preliminary injunction which will
prohibit the government from enforcing
any such mandate now the third time
federal judges have sided with attorney
general wilson and blocked enforcement
of biden administration vaccine
requirements this is really really
spectacular news and for all of us that
are worried about america worried
whether this thing is working anymore
whether we have separation of powers
whether we've handed all the power to
the president all of that stuff it's
like it shows you there's some fight
left in the system there are individual
people in this case judges who are
saying i still will stand up for what's
right i will not let
the president decide what private
companies what must do whether federal
contractors or just basic companies who
work with the federal government on a
little project meaning if the federal
government is building a building and
you're a contractor who comes in because
you do some lighting or you do some
landscaping that you have to have all
your people vaccinated too it was
absolutely bananas to begin with and
this is like it's just great news it's
just great news it does not matter what
you think about vaccines if you are
vaccinated and you want to vaccinate
everyone around you and you never want
to leave your house and as i always say
wrap your head in saran wrap and all
that good stuff that's just wonderful
this is a different issue this is about
whether a top-down system will decide
what you inject yourself with when you
inject it how many times you inject it
and how long you must bow to them before
they give you some of your freedoms back
so this is a great great moment
that's how we're starting off the show
we got four stories for you remember
this hillary clinton woman she's back
and just saying a whole bunch of stuff
that you know she's just it's hillary
clinton we'll throw to that uh then joe
biden and his administration they
basically admitted that they coordinate
stories with the media surprise surprise
it's like we all know that they do it
but now they're actually like straight
up admitting it we'll get to that lori
lightfoot the uh mayor of chicago who's
broken her own vaccine mandates a
million times and defunded the police
and has brought in every woke idiotic
leftist progressive policy possible now
she's blaming store owners for the crime
it's the store owners who aren't doing
as much basically uh blaming the victims
and then finally
i saw this video yesterday it's actually
quite extraordinary it's from right
before the lockdowns uh it's a holocaust
survivor someone who survived from
auschwitz
talking about the creep of
authoritarianism and what it was like
before they put people
into the concentration camps it's really
really extraordinary and i know that
everyone makes
nazi comparisons and we've we've
butchered these words we've we've
butchered history it's really
unfortunate but i saw this video
yesterday i said we have to we have to
show this um because i think you will
see the parallels
to today's society so those are the four
stories for today before i get to any of
that i want to talk to you guys about
janusel you know take a quick look in
the mirror you see those bags under your
eyes not undermined though imagine them
gone you can get rid of that puffiness
just in time for the holiday season
introducing genius cell plant stem cell
therapy for bags and puffiness under the
eyes you know when i look back on that
first prageru video i did i was stressed
i wasn't sleeping much and i see big
bags under my eyes but no more people my
assistant told me she's enjoying the
geniuselle products we received so much
that she's sharing them with family and
friends she really does love them shout
out to helen uh better yet with
janusel's immediate effects you'll see
results in the first 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back from now until
christmas geniuselle's most popular
package is 60 off at love geniuselle.com
dave that's 60
treat yourself and a loved one to the
absolute best skin care in the world
just go to love
g-e-n-u-c-e-l dot com slash dave and
enter my special promo code for an extra
special holiday present that's
lovejandycell.com dave love
geniusell.com dave and now back to me
all right hillary clinton she's back
just when you thought that politics
wasn't crazy enough we haven't heard
from hillary in a while well she gave a
speech the other day explaining what
feminism means to her and i'm fairly
certain she needs a time machine take a
look when people ask me well
what does feminism mean or what does it
mean to be a feminist i say it means
that you are
in favor for the full
and equal participation of women in
political civil economic and cultural
life
and that
that is a positive statement that is an
affirmative call to action
yeah no [ __ ] lady everybody believes
that but that has nothing to do
with modern feminism everyone you cannot
find someone i would welcome you to look
for them hunt them down bring them to me
tied up
and show me the person in america right
now who doesn't believe that women
should have full participation in
political civil economic and cultural
life everyone believes that women men
and women are different men and women
make different choices
men tend to like things more so they
become engineers women tend to like
people more so they might become nurses
at a higher rate
but that's okay men and women are
different so what hillary is describing
there is first wave feminism she's
talking about feminism from 1960s let's
make sure women are fully equal right
and we know the gender pay gap doesn't
exist if you don't believe me on that
and i know you probably believe me but a
lot of your friends don't might i
recommend the prageru video that
christina hoff summers did on the myth
of the gender pay gap it simply doesn't
exist men and women make different
choices they do different careers and
that's just fine you know it's actually
kind of cool that often and for the most
part of history that women stayed home
and raised the kids and if the father
could have one job that could support
everything it was pretty sweet then
women traded a lot of that in so that
they put their career first and it's
like is anyone happier because of that
now they should have every opportunity
to do all of those things
but i can tell you this my dad worked
very hard for many many years he retired
about a year and a half ago at 70
something years old worked at the same
company for about 40 years commuted two
hours a day on the long island railroad
uh into manhattan
so that he could afford us a good life
and my mom fortunately for my formative
years of for me and my brother and my
sister my mom was able to be a
stay-at-home mom and took good care of
us and opened the door when we got home
from school and made sure we had snacks
and made our lunch and made our
breakfast and all of that stuff and it
was pretty freaking good and then when
we were all out of the house my mom went
back into the workforce and became a
nursery school teacher that's a
beautiful thing men and women are
different so what hillary's saying there
actually is correct and i like to give
credit where credit is due except she's
saying something that's utterly
meaningless relative to modern feminism
right modern feminism is that men should
beat women in wrestling right biological
men should be women wrestling that's a
feminist position
of now we know all of this nonsense the
uh what is she again rachel levine she
is the secretary of something or other
in the health services something
something you know who i'm talking about
the biological man named rachel levine
that's just fine i'll even refer to him
as her
she
was we're being told is the first female
tran or the first female health
secretary something like that that's
what the surgeon general said that's
what the abiding administration said
it's like no she's not a female she's a
trans woman okay that's just fine this
is a man who chooses to live his life as
a woman trans person okay i'm not even
not casting aspersions on that or even
pacing judgment on that but the modern
feminist movement has feminists
applauding as a biological man becomes
the first trans health secretary or
whatever what is she she's the health
secretary the deputy health secretary of
health of something something it doesn't
look that healthy but okay whatever um
so anyway the point here is that yes
hillary you are right and in the way you
define
feminism that women should be able to do
the same [ __ ] men do if they want to do
it and maybe they do and maybe they
don't i'm on board with with you hillary
but you're giving a speech
from
1974 you're not giving a speech from uh
2021. so get with the times hillary if
you're watching just come on you're
you're on your way you're gonna be all
right uh speaking of political
people and people that aren't really
with the times uh joe biden who as you
know is the acting president of the
united states this is a man who uh gives
speeches every now and again and then
accidentally when he goes off
teleprompter always says that he's going
to get in trouble when he starts telling
you the truth or he loses his train of
thought or fumbles and mumbles or runs
away from questions or they hide him or
all this stuff nonetheless the guy is
supposedly the president
now it is coming out that basically the
administration is coordinating with
mainstream media because they don't like
some of the coverage they're getting now
before i read you the the quotes from
the daily wire really think about how
crazy this is we had four years of the
orange man being president where every
single story was about racism and
xenophobia and this is hitler and a
democracy is over and everything there's
basically in the mainstream there's
really no criticism of biden you know
like sure we're having supply chain
problems inflation is a disaster in
afghanistan like the list goes on and on
but there's really no criticism real
criticism of biden they either blame it
on trump or it's not you know biden's
doing the best he can he released two
days worth of gas you know the guy's
trying at least two days around the gas
that's fun uh anyway uh the
administration basically is coordinating
now with mainstream media on how they
should cover them we've got some info
here from the daily wire
cnn reported the white house not happy
with news media coverage news media's
coverage of the supply chain and economy
has been working behind the scenes
trying to reshape cover coverage in its
favor senior white house and
administration officials including nec
deputy directors david camen and bharat
rammuti along with envoy john porsari
have been briefing major newsrooms over
the past week a source tells me the
officials have been discussing with
newsroom trends pertaining to job
creation economic growth supply chains
and more the basic argument that has
been made that the country's economy is
in much better shape than it was last
year i'm told the conversations have
been productive with anchors and
reporters and producers getting to talk
with the officials biden's approval
rating is so low that he has had a lower
approval rating that than every governor
in the u.s and his approval rating has
dipped to as low as 18
in one state so first off on the biden
approval rating thing i mean this is the
man he got 81 million votes and don't
you doubt it
his approval rating is just absolutely
in the tank okay that doesn't matter
this idea though
that administration officials
go to newsrooms talk to news anchors
talk to reporters and journalists and
help them craft coverage does that sound
like journalism to you does that sound
like michael can you get me the
definition of the word journalism we're
going to get the definition the very
definition of the word does that sound
like journalism or does that sound like
scripting does that sound like uh
getting an approved narrative across
right if you're going into a room and
you're trying to get people to say the
things that you want them to say so
that's what they're doing they're
administration officials oh well the
economy is better than you think it is
and we're going to show you these things
that that sounds like what hollywood
would do not what journalism would do
i've got the very definition of the word
journalism journalism is the production
and distribution of reports on current
events based on facts and supported with
proof or evidence
well that sounds like journalism as we
knew it not journalism as we know it
anyway i suppose this doesn't surprise
any of you because obviously it didn't
surprise me but it was worth mentioning
because it's like the administration's
admitting it like we know all the stuff
they do behind the scenes right they
leak things to the new york times they
leak things to the washington post they
cover up things when it doesn't fit the
narrative but they're literally right in
front of our faces saying guys in
essence what they're saying is guys we
hand them the script we talk to the news
anchors wonder if they talk to chris
cuomo i wonder if they talk to don lemon
wonder if they talk to it talk to some
of these people you know it's like and
then you watch this stuff and you think
you're getting fact-based or proof or
evidence-based reporting from honest
people and what you're actually getting
is pravda you're actually just getting
talking points from the administration
you don't need talking points from an
administration to go
down the street like i can over here and
basically still see all of these boarded
up stores or virtually every single
store almost without exception saying 15
an hour we're hiring people can't get
people to work because people are now on
the government dole these companies
these businesses these diners these
restaurants i assure you they're not
thriving and the idea i'll try to give
the devil is due
if
you believe the economies say a little
bit better than it was last year well
last year we were supposedly in the
worst pandemic of all time the pandemic
that the vaccines and old joe biden were
supposed to fix so is it possible at
some level at some analysis of the data
that the economy is a little bit better
now than when we were in sort of still
full lockdowns or half lockdowns or
whatever i suppose that might be true at
some level but you'd have to do a lot of
narrative work you'd have to do a lot of
fiction writing to make it really hold
water so anyway i don't believe these
people that's the bumper sticker for
that one and speaking of people
that i don't believe lori lightfoot is
the progressive
mayor of chicago this is a woman who at
the height of the pandemic was telling
everyone to stay home and stay masked
who was out on the streets unmasked with
the rioters as they were burning down
her city as you know chicago which has
some of the strictest if not the
strictest gun laws in the country also
has an insane amount of gun murders
every weekend could we get the numbers
on the gun murders of chicago this past
weekend uh she has defunded the police
she has brought in every idiotic
progressive policy possible we've got
the numbers already at least 46 people
were shot in chicago this weekend now
why is it why is it that you wouldn't
have heard about that
hmm
is it that they maybe want to cover it
up because they don't like the skin
color of the people who did the shooting
and who got shot it doesn't fit the
narrative could that be it could it also
expose that the gun laws that these
ridiculous people have don't work at all
yeah yeah anyway
she uh she defunded the police chicago
is a freaking nightmare at the moment
much like portland much like seattle
much like san francisco much like la you
guys get it all but now she has the gall
the absolute gall
to blame the business owners and this is
very much like a video we showed you
about two weeks ago remember we had a
video out of minnesota where ilhan omar
who also defunded the police in
minnesota where she was blaming the
police officers now for not doing their
job so she defunds the police crime
increases murder increases general
mayhem and chaos ensues and then she
blames the people that she defunded in
the first place well here's just a short
video of lori lightfoot blaming the
business owners for not doing enough to
protect their own businesses
i'm disappointed that they're not doing
more to take safety
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
institute um plans like having security
officers in their stores making sure um
that they've got cameras that are
actually operational
oh god she's so ridiculous so you defund
the police people feel that they can
commit crimes more we know about all
these da's who don't prosecute crimes
right so you're allowed to steal a
certain amount of stuff and instead of
her looking in the mirror although i can
get why she doesn't want to look in the
mirror instead of her looking in the
mirror and saying oh maybe i had
something to do with this maybe my
policies even though i think i'm a good
tolerant progressive and everything i do
is good just because i believe it's good
maybe my policies are increasing crime
right like i did this now this happened
maybe there's a connection you know who
knows
instead of doing that though she's
blaming the business owners for not
having more security in their stores you
know in a sane society you wouldn't need
a lot of security in stores um in just
think anyone watching this think about
your childhood wherever you went if you
went to a drugstore if you went to a
clothing store you went to a sneaker
store usually they didn't have security
maybe occasionally at some stores like
at a best buy they'd have a guy at the
door right because there's a lot of you
know electronic equipment expensive
stuff but you could walk into a foot
locker and there wouldn't be a need for
a security guy there you could walk into
h m and it's not like they're really
worried that someone's gonna steal that
six dollar t-shirt but now all of these
stores have security guys and it's
because
the government is not doing its job it's
in a direct dereliction of its very duty
so she's blaming the stores for not
doing enough the stores which are
already struggling by the way they're
struggling because the economy ain't
great sorry joe the stores are
struggling so maybe they can't even
afford to have these people there right
they can't afford to hire more people
when you're struggling it's basic math i
know those guys don't like math either
so
what do we do what do we do when you
have a whole bunch of politicians who
don't understand or are intentionally
doing it i mean actually i'm tired of
giving these people uh you know the good
intentions thing okay like oh your
intentions are good well if the results
are always bad at some point we can't
play that game anymore so either she
wants to destroy chicago or she's an
idiot i i don't know what the two
options beyond that would be so she's
blaming they're not hiring enough
security even though it should be her
job to make sure that you know we we
live in a
that her constituents live in a lawful
city and they don't have enough cameras
there well the cameras are meaningless
too because if she's if they caught all
the people stealing the crap they
wouldn't prosecute them anyway right we
know this i mean every day you go on
twitter at any given moment there's just
endless looting happening all over the
country and it's like yeah it's all
caught on video but
they're not gonna do anything about that
so lori lightfoot i don't like you uh
all right let's move on i think this is
uh well this is gonna be a very sobering
uh topic but i thought this was the
right way to end the show today i saw
this video yesterday
it's from january of 2020 which
obviously is right before
the pandemic this is a survivor of the
holocaust survivor actually of auschwitz
concentration camp his name is marion
turski
and he
gives a talk we're going to show you
about two minutes of it right now he was
94 years old at the time of this speech
and he talks really about the step
step-by-step
step-by-step slow progression of how you
demonize people how you other people and
how authoritarianism creeps in and i saw
this yesterday and i thought i have to
show this on the show
it's not current events but perhaps
it's exactly current events so take a
look one day
in those early 1930s
you can read
an inscription on the benches jews must
not sit on these benches you could say
it's unpleasant it's not fair it's not
right but after all there are so many
benches around
you can sit somewhere else of course you
can
there was a swimming pool
and over its door and inscription red
jews are forbidden to enter you could
say well pleasant this is not but there
are so many plates in berlin where you
can take a bath or swim so many lakes
canals it's nearly like venice
at the same time
you can read somewhere else jews must
not belong to german singing
associations so what all right they want
to sing they want to make music
let them just meet somewhere else they
will do their singing all right what
comes up later
is an order really more of an order than
of an inscription non-aryan children
must not play with aryan children with
the german children all right they'll
play
choice this makes your life harder but
after all
after 5pm you can still do your shopping
and that's how it is done step by step
slowly
and
they become
acquainted with that thoughts familiar
with the idea
that they are different people that they
are alien people that they are the
people that carry germs that cause
pandemics
and this now
is a horror
what came later was something that
developed immediately jews could not get
jobs they could not emigrate
and then quickly
jews would be sent to ghettos
to riga to my ghetto
ashes did not fall suddenly from the
skies
it was literally patterning in all those
tiny steps it was approaching
until
what happened here behind me did happen
there's actually nothing that i can add
to that so i will only ask a question
before i end the show today
which is
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
all right see you guys tomorrow